[Music]
music icon Neil Diamond made a stunning
announcement yesterday just two days shy
of his 77th birthday diamond whose
concerts still sell out arenas around
the world is retiring from touring
effective immediately because of a
serious health condition
[Music]
the legendary singer announced he has
Parkinson's disease the condition has
forced him to cancel the upcoming dates
of his 50th anniversary tour in a
statement he says quote this ride has
been so good so good so good
thanks to you man
his last public performance was New
Year's Eve his hand was visibly shaking
Parkinson's has made it difficult for
Dimon to perform on a large-scale basis
but he will continue to write and record
to America
in 2009 the Brooklyn native headlined a
CBS special from New York's Madison
Square Garden I played to all kinds of
people but there's nothing quite like
coming home
[Music]
Ian barber strikes and went to high
school together and performed a duet at
the 1980 Grammys
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Applause]
[Music]